The Joe Rogan Experience how much are
you worried about an actual situation
like that happening I mean I don't know
everything's so weird
Elon took over Twitter today yeah like
we live in a simulation no that's the
best that crazy bastard did it how about
when he walked into Twitter's
headquarters with a sink and said let
that sink in okay a dad joke yes that's
him I know he's funny we have like this
ongoing bet on dumpster fire that he's
my Nemesis and it started because of my
husband who we were doing one of these
dumb books someone got us it's like oh
you can like connect as a couple and we
were jokingly kind of ironically in our
Gen X way doing it and it was like
what's something you would like always
want to do or something like that he was
like have dinner with Elon Musk and I
was like it was supposed to be something
about me and I was like [ __ ] you you're
gonna have dinner with Elon not have
dinner with me and so it became his
ongoing joke because of him being my
nemesis
because it's hilarious because I'm a
nobody and he's a genius buying Twitter
and sending Rockets to space and trying
to get to Mars and I'm screaming in a
garage on dumpster fire so there's that
hilarious aspect but it's mostly just
because he's my it became this ongoing
joke because my husband started joking
about his like you know enamored being
enamored with Elon Musk and so I was
just jealous
so he became like it's just become this
ongoing and then somebody sent us an
e-line cutout for the set and it's so
cool whenever we do an Elon is my nemus
and I'm like my Nemesis is up to what's
he up to now and we like bring the
cutout on for the for the bet well we're
hoping we can get our girl Megan uh
re-re established free Megan free Megan
Murphy free Megan there's so many yeah
people were like there's so many people
that need to be re-established so I mean
James Lindsay got booted I think yes
um and somebody was like this is like
when the Joker let all the all the all
the prisoners out
yeah but it's not it's not because we'll
have to see them as like political
prisoners might be
those those are crazy paranoid people
that have been also they've been
enjoying the fact that it's an
ideological thought bubble right that
Twitter has only enforced left left-wing
ideologies and they've suppressed any
conservative ideologies even amongst
reasonable kind people that don't share
the same ideology that's [ __ ] bad for
our society yeah it's bad I'm not a huge
proponent of like the parallel economies
either you know I I just I I don't know
that it's good you know you what do you
mean by parallel this is like the term
that everybody's using particularly on
the right because and it's it's valid as
these places like PayPal and financial
institutions are saying you can't you
know if you say this or step out of line
we're gonna find you there's this idea
that you're gonna have to create a
parallel a kind anime in order to
function essentially so don't give don't
give your money to I mean I think the
daily wire did it with the razors they
had like hairs yeah they did and Jeremy
did some razors so it's like oh don't
give your money to people who hate you
give your money to people who
share your ideology but then you have
these side you know the silos are
forming where it's like then everyone's
over here and everyone who agrees is
over here and no one's forced to
actually
articulate their ideas or disagree with
one another it's just everyone like
smelling their own farts
it is though yeah that's not healthy no
that's what Elon wants to bring back to
Twitter is reasonable exchange of ideas
that's like he really thinks it's
important it is important it is I think
it's important too but it's just rare
that someone is that wealthy that they
can do that that can do that and also he
was very left-leaning for most of his
life yeah until really recently the
pandemic in particular and the way
people have sort of enforced these
ideologies regardless of whether or not
the science supports it yeah and he
thinks it's bad and I think it's true I
think I think we have a real problem
with Discord particularly like discourse
on Twitter right like if you post
something and then someone posts
something that opposes what you say like
ah and then you gotta like formulate it
like some people don't want that so what
they would like to do is silence the
people that have opposing viewpoints and
then you get all this positive feedback
from all the people that agree with you
you're like yes I want to amplify that
because that feels good I did the right
I said the right thing I said the right
and then when someone comes in with
facts or opinion [ __ ] you you Nazi
fascist and it's like that's what people
are doing now because it's a [ __ ] way to
communicate communicating like that it's
good it's a good way to get out
information and ideas really quickly but
it's a bad way to exchange ideas and to
dialogue about stuff because it's
the way people are supposed to really
communicate is like how we're doing yeah
two people looking at each other talking
that's how we're designed we're not
really designed to read text no